let's get controversial with it we have
this tweet from Elijah Shafer that he
put up shortly before the show and it's
the image from the execution with
Dilbert and it says quote there's no
fixing this and um obviously it's ingest
but he's making a point about what Scott
Adams said and Scott Adams uh the
creative Dilbert flow is not familiar he
did a show where he basically was
talking about the effects of critical
race Theory the effects of the left's
racial views and he was talking about
how racial tensions are getting worse
and worse the more they fan the flames
and and then he he said
hyperbolically I might add and they took
it out of context that he would
encourage people to get away uh he would
encourage white people to get away from
black people this is what of course
Elijah Shaffer is pointing to here's
here's why I wanted to bring this up
the first thing I want to say is because
we talked about Scott Adams things last
night is that it seems like after he if
you look at the full context of what he
was saying and a lighter clarification
he did not believe the Rasmussen poll
was sound data he was making a point
about if the data were true and this is
what we're seeing with the expansion of
CRT then he's saying fine if that's what
the left wants this is the advice you'd
have to give to somebody in fact Scott
Adams was actually saying that he would
advise based on critical race Theory and
diversity hiring and stuff a black
person to move to an all-white area so
that he could get the diversity job
because that's the system created by
critical race Theory so he's actually
being very critical of this and was
opposing segregation and it's uh but I
think he dropped a nuke on the
conversation on purpose the reason why I
wanted to highlight Elijah Schaefer's
tweet in the context of this uh
execution in broad daylight is that
whether Elijah is intending to express
actual concern or just making a joke
being like look this guy making a meme
about it people are going to feel this
way people are going to see what happens
with Scott Adams they're going to hear
what he said he says then they're going
to see this video going viral and it's
like millions of views and they are
going to take it to a racial place so
the problem I have with what's going on
I mean first of all our culture is
decaying and it's because of what
they're doing in schools what they're
teaching kids they're teaching them
weird cult ideologies about how you know
minorities can't succeed and things like
that which is generating hatred and
animosity
you've got ABC News Univision funding an
organization this is the company I
worked at Fusion where the
editor-in-chief's Twitter profile says
down with whiteness and I'm like what do
you think happens when you go around
telling people to hate each other based
on race the funny thing is they're mad
at Scott Adams about it
you'll get things like this again not
not saying Elijah for is taking it
literally I think he's he's memeing and
being you know edgy on purpose but
there's going to be a lot of people in
this country who are going to look at
that and say yes
and that's a function of the left
they've been pushing for segregation in
every corner of our society for years
you know they call for segregation in
schools they they create black only
dorms in elementary school they teach
kids that America is fundamentally
racist and so for the left then to go
and you know claim and uh you know that
I was essentially saying that you know
if this is what you're calling for then
fine and then calling that that race
it's like you can't have it both ways
you can't claim that we should segregate
and then somebody says okay and then
call them races for it they are going to
try to have it both ways they have
arguments prepared for people that say
that you can't have it both ways the
arguments won't make sense unless you
understand their lexicon they share a
vocabulary but they do not share a
dictionary the things that they say when
you say racist they will have double
meanings whether it's a position of
power uh and privilege or if it's a
whatever Prejudice whatever whatever
fits there attempted winning an argument
yeah I mean therefore they win in chaos
right when people disagree they Thrive a
lot of times it boils down to a
fundamental philosophy that is illiberal
they are a lot of times you get
consequentialists on the left that
believe that whatever they do is okay if
the consequences are good they are the
and the the most important point is they
are illiberal the the left has moved
Beyond liberalism it is now Progressive
so they do they support things like
segregation because they believe that
present discrimination is what fixes
past discrimination and the only thing
that will fix present discrimination is
future discrimination these are things
that are ubiquitous and the left
currently and it's infested Palo friary
school programs and the curriculum it's
a horrible thing that's going on and we
need to get Paulo Fieri's influence out
of schools I was thinking about this you
know because we were out here where we
are we're away from the cities we got
local farms you drive five minutes from
here and there's a farm stand with
grass-fed organic beef and the funny
thing is they don't call it that they
just call it ground beef but it's
because it's from a farm the cows ate
grass and then they like they didn't put
chemicals or anything in it and I was
thinking about that as so I tweeted
something but I'll show you a sort of
Correction here's how I feel
conservatism is organic grass-fed beef
not because it's a premium product
because that's literally the way you
raise cattle you let it walk around
eating grass liberalism modern you know
neoliberalism is GMO fed genetically
modified uh corn it's corn fed
genetically modified cloned beef mass
produced at a low price and available at
your local supermarket and Progressive
progressivism is
plant-based beef with a pH food product
available in your your vegan food aisle
and I I do feel like you know it's a
silly joke but it does kind of exemplify
a lot more than just
the meat the meat argument like I was I
was I was talking to a friend about
where they could get you know farm fresh
meats or whatever I thought about it I'm
like man if you go to like the Corporate
Center you're going to get corn fed GMO
beef or whatever and if you go to the
farm you're getting the good stuff but
the farmers are all conservative I
thought that was kind of funny and uh
but but it's it's everything else I mean
think about what what schools are like
for your average liberal it's March and
lockstep it's the it's mechanized the
machine it's the high fructose corn
syrup plastic bottle but then you look
at what's happening now with
progressivism seeping in and now it's
the crazy gender ideology CRT race-based
everything and it's it's it's it's it's
crazy because it's it's imploding on
itself in a sense
they claim racism is a problem while
actively being racist it's it's it's
it's an amazing Paradox but I guess it's
just destroying the foundations of our
institutions and ripping the culture
apart it's resulting in people hating
each other and fighting dividing
concrete it's feeding racial tension
there's this Gallup poll from 2019 and I
hate to bring up another poll I know no
we don't love them this week but uh in
2019 they found that for the first time
since the poll started in 20 2001 uh
more black Americans are saying race
relationships with white people are at
an all-time like they're the worst
they've ever been they're they describe
them as the majority of black people 59
described race relations with white
people as bad but white people didn't
have this perception right and this is
before everything that happened with
George Floyd and our very very public
discussions of race especially when it
comes to white versus black Americans
This was 2019 it was the year before I
think that we've had like you were
saying uh conversation about race that
actually don't heal communities and
don't encourage understanding they pit
people against one another and there's
no you sort of can't be surprised when
we have this cartoonist saying like well
this is where we're headed perhaps we
should all split up take a look at this
uh this is a a quote from a news article
it says Adams is currently embroiled in
a public Scandal following advice he
doled out last week when he told white
people to get the hell away from black
people citing a poll that found nearly
half of black people are not okay with
white people it's like okay well hold on
there that's not really what the poll
said and Scott Adams said he was being
hyperbolic and he even said he does not
think the data from that poll is
absolute or sound and he thinks people
should be treated like individuals but
his point was like if there's a poll
that tells you half of this group of
people doesn't like you you probably
don't want to be around them I mean so
imagine if you put it the other way and
it said the poll said half of white
people didn't want to didn't think it
was okay to be black and then someone
told black people to to fear or get away
from white people that's literally what
this the critical race theorists are
doing right now well this is literally
what the left wants the liberal says
that race isn't the most important
factor about you it is the content of
your character the left says no actually
your skin color does determine your
worth your skin color does determine if
you will be successful and it reminds me
of the the Morgan Freeman clip where he
says you know how do you get rid of
racism will you stop talking about it or
Idris Elba recently came out and he says
I want to stop being known as a black
actor I just want to be an actor and
then today this clip going viral of Issa
Ray saying that you know I'm rooting for
black I'm just supporting anybody who's
black that's winning and it's crazy that
today we still have to point out that
you are not valuable based on your
immutable characteristics that it is
your abilities it is your talents it is
the work you put in but the left doesn't
want that they want you to be
constrained and confined by your
immutable characteristics because then
they can control You by them happy and
content people do not uh engage in
Revolutionary activities
period they don't the the left desires a
revolution because they are illiberal
they don't like the principles that this
country was founded on the liberal
principles that this country was founded
on they want a revolution so the more
people that are unhappy and dissatisfied
with their lives the better for the left
period that's the way that it is because
you don't get revolutionaries from
content happy satisfied people if your
Society is is mostly happy and most
people are satisfied and most people
feel good and have hope for the future
you don't get Revolution why risk it why
why risk the good things you have going
right now what they have to do is
convince people that things are bad so I
saw this viral video of some kid and
he's like I live with my parents and my
girlfriend because I can't afford rent
because to even get some place to live
like a studio or one bedroom was like a
thousand bucks per person that's insane
how can anyone afford that right make
sure that people can't afford to live
and you guarantee yourself a revolution
so
maybe that's why they're building
bunkers in New Zealand because they're
preparing for something that uh I guess
we can all see coming and probably
should prepare for too
I mean I don't want to talk about the
possibility of like crazy International
globalist creating a nuclear war to kill
off a bunch anything about that I I'm
talking about economic crisis in which
you get socialism and so they have
ranches in New Zealand
but these this this is literally what's
happening the wealthiest people in the
world are building these properties in
New Zealand having bought citizenship
there having bought citizenship there
and other places like Saint Kitts and
Nevis you can buy citizenship there and
then you're looking at all the failed
policy brought about by the Democrats
and the The Establishment Republicans
which result in 2 000 bucks for a studio
apartment a person can't afford then you
get a bunch of young people saying this
is the worst ever been the system is
impossible what am I supposed to do and
then Along Comes A Marxist saying hey
agree with me and then we'll take it
from everybody and say sure why not I
can't get it anyway
so that's literally happening whether
intentional or not is it doesn't matter
yeah I think one of the interesting
things about all conspiracy theories is
that if a thing is happening and then
someone comes out and says I believe
thing happening is the result of a
person wanting it to happen they say
yeah you're a conspiracy theorist but
you then come out and be like I got no
idea why but things happening and well
is that a conspiracy no I never said
anybody who's doing on purpose like like
population reduction how about this how
about we're seeing across the around the
world countries are are seeing their
populations decline you've got people in
the United States sterilizing their kids
aborting their kids or just outright
advocating not to have kids with climate
change
it's happening climate reduction I'm
sorry um population reduction is
literally happening now the question is
can you prove an individual or
individuals have been implementing these
policies with the intentions
specifically of reducing population well
the answer there is yes not all of it
I'm not saying every single instance of
every single uh active that reduces
population I'm saying Bill Gates goes on
stage and says we have to reduce
population so the funny thing is this is
a conspiracy theory that powerful Elites
have advocated for and talked about
incessantly that there are too many
people since what the 70s the malthusian
ism or whatever
and then you've got Klaus Schwab you've
got Bill Gates you've got these powerful
Global Elites saying here are the things
we're going to do to reduce population
growth then you start seeing policies
implemented that reduce population
growth okay fine I'm not saying young
women are being encouraged to get
abortions because Bill Gates is funding
super Pacs or anything like that I'm
just saying sure is can great for him
that the thing he wants to happen is
happening you know so it happens people
want it to happen there you go that's as
far as I'll go with it thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time